[Music]
today what we're going to share with you
is not groundbreaking I can assure you
that that this is a lot of the stuff is
stuff that you've probably heard but as
the saying goes it's not the mountains
that we stumbled on it's the pebbles so
if we cross the pebble each pebble by
pebble soon we would have crossed the
mountain so today we are here to share
with you how we've crossed one of our
biggest mountains over the last two and
a half years and what it has taken us to
get there sharing with you our vision
our strategy our building blocks and the
journey that we've covered over the last
few years so just to walk you through
very quickly we will we will share with
you the structure that we put in place
our focus areas and our core objectives
the vision that has allowed us to
deliver to our strategy help us map
method relies what we were to deliver
and more importantly how we build our
structure and our wealth our wealth in
terms of our resources our people our
teams and more importantly our tools of
trade we want to cover the journey the
way this this program started off in
2016 and the way we've we've journeyed
through 2017 and to date our building
blocks around our architecture our core
focus our roadmap the way we've brought
our service management our on and
automation our operations together to be
to be able to make this a success and
finally we want to close with what were
the challenges and some of the food for
thought and recommendations that we
would like to leave with you when we
started this journey it was important
for us to be able to have a clear vision
to be able to have a vision that would
help us build a strategy that would
allow us to make the leap from our
legacy data centers into public cloud
our focus areas were around having a
very clear and stable and optimized
presence in the public and the private
cloud that is where we were going to
live for the rest of our lives and we
wanted to make sure that we were going
to build that strongly we wanted to be
able to use our learnings
what we were doing in the legacy data
centers to be able to get better savings
through optimizations we wanted to
provide agility to our business we
wanted to provide simplicity to our
business and most importantly enablement
enablement of technology solutions and
services and this is where we had to we
had to carve out what our two core
strategies were going to be one of the
strategies for Schlumberger an
organization that has been for over a
hundred years with 100 100 thousand plus
employees over 85 countries was to be
able to live in the public cloud so we
had to move all our legacy data centers
to the public private cloud in a multi
cloud environment the second strategy
was to be able to not only move to
public cloud but also be able to bring
the managed services in-house and be
able to understand how we do that better
and be able to optimize our performance
of operating our our applications in
public cloud this journey over 2018 was
focusing around our digital enablement
our savings and optimizations and most
importantly our operational enablement
one of the important areas for us was to
be able to provide our business the
ability the simplicity and the agility
to be able to optimize the oil and gas
business in in the tough times that
we've had over the last few years as we
journeyed along it was important for us
to not only focus on our objectives and
our core areas but it was also important
that we look at how we structure our
coal delivery areas it was important for
us as a program to build the life of the
program but also what the core focus
areas in the the delivery areas were
going to be and when I say that it was
imperative for us as an organization to
focus on how we were going to structure
our architecture our service and
automation our delivery pillars and most
importantly our operations when the
journey started it was more around how
you've been given a block of land this
is the analogy that's that's that's been
there from the time we started the the
program you've been given a block of
land and now you're expected to actually
move your furniture that's what you're
doing
but before you can move your furniture
it is important for you to have a house
and for you to have a house it's
important for you to have the
architecture on what you're going to be
building it your utilities all your
supplies and so it was a journey that we
had to to sort of structure a plan and
put the foundation blocks to be able to
to get to where we are today in 2019
what we are going to be focusing on is
taking that journey to the next step so
take a step back over 2016 over 2017 our
focus areas have been on how do we put a
methodology you've you've probably heard
a lot about the lift and shift you've
you've heard about the rebuild really
texture remodeling replanting and all of
that is very true and and I assure you
that you probably heard in in sessions
yesterday that the core piece of being
able to migrate applications from your
legacy data centers to public and
private cloud lies in your ability to do
a thorough assessment of what your
applications look like understanding
your technology and your legacy debt
understanding what are your your
constraints around your licensing
abilities and most importantly making
sure that you have the right partners in
in helping you drive that journey in
2018 we successfully closed one of our
core data centers and we migrated four
hundred-plus applications to public and
private cloud this for anyone who's
who's embarked on the journey will
realize that over the two years
achieving this has been a a cornerstone
for us in 2019 now that we we have a a
presence and and our footing in public
cloud our focus is now on how we start
to optimize automate and start to
exploit the the native offerings in in
cloud this is a a journey roadmap that
is that is that's been a a one slide
that helps us talk about what that
journey has been and how we've we've
moved from cradle to grave on the on the
overall project what it shows you is
that if you look at the if you look at
the big blue bar that
basically our foundation our roadmap
that's our journey everything you see on
top of the blue bar is the fruits of our
migrations that's basically everything
that is tangible that has allowed us to
complete our pilots move into our our
discovery phase exit our are our data
centers but at the same time start a
modernization journey but none of the
things that you see above the blue line
would have been possible if the routes
which you see below the blue line which
is where our partner in in Google our
partner in our multi cloud strategy have
actually helped us build those footings
so as we grow as an enterprise in the
public and the private cloud space we
grow with with with our partners in
Google and our partners in in Azure and
our private data centers so what you see
a below is is is what we will be talking
a bit more in our architecture
discussions but what you see above the
line is where we are focusing more on
the journey that has happened where
we've sort of structured over 2016 to
2017 and 2018 when the program started
in in 2016 the expectation was for us to
close down our legacy data centers and
have everything in public and private
cloud it was a quite a stretched and and
a challenging target for us to to
achieve we had to put some structure we
had to put some methodology we had to
put some some robust teams in place to
help us journey along this road one of
those things that is become more and
more evident to us as we journey down as
we needed to make sure that we had the
right partners working with us right and
and as we as we close the session today
we will share a bit more about how we've
journeyed through that and how we've
made sure that those partners I'll have
have come along with us and grown with
us as the public cloud offerings have
drawn whatwhat what you see or on this
slide is also telling you that in 2016
when we started the journey our focus
was on doing a proof-of-concept doing a
thorough
meant of our applications to understand
a what were what was our application
landscape in terms of simple medium and
complex but also what our methodology
for migration was going to be around
lifted shift versus rebuild versus
really tech tree platform
this assessment helped us carve out what
our 2017 roadmap was going to look like
where we journeyed along and we took a a
major chunk of our applications and
successfully got that across to give us
a validation of our methodology in 2018
that became a more well-oiled machine
and that has helped us move and journey
along and and shut down one of our core
data centers that was one of our legacy
data centers and holding about 400 plus
applications at that data center what
has happened along the way is with with
with Google and with our multi cloud
partners we've built the infrastructure
as a service offerings that has helped
us pave the path not only for footing in
the infrastructure as a service but
subsequently now as we journey along to
modernize our applications make them
more pass ready and then subsequently
take them into containers now this could
not have been possible without the
support of our architecture without the
support of our strategy around how are
we going to bring service management
in-house how are we going to focus on
structure izing our operational support
and this is some of those things that we
want to talk about as we as we go
through the session today what I would
like to do now is I would like to invite
my colleague
Sadia who is our lead architect on the
program to walk us through the core
focus areas for architecture thank you
for the introduction bazaar so I think
if you guys were here for a movie
session I'm loving this environment this
is this is the wrong session the session
here that we have is covering our
journey and what we have done within
public cloud and
our partners and team around within
shaumbra so before i even cover our
areas of focus one thing that i want to
cover is from an organization's
perspective what we have our guiding
principles and support from our
architecture and governance body and a
bias of my own team the principles that
we follow is cloud first if you are
trying to solve a business problem or a
technical problem at hand bias towards
cloud native technology and solutions
that is where we partner with our cloud
service providers with our tam teams
with the engineers that work with us
and then lastly it's very difficult to
predict where next six months are gonna
be so what we do is one of the guiding
principles that we have is any decision
we take we have to reduce friction so
when it comes to taking decisions making
up your mind picking a technology it is
a very quick pre decision when we go
through these three steps that being
said what we you see here is it looks
like a laundry list of things it's
because it is a laundry list of things
we have them categorized so we can focus
our energies or workstream and our
efforts in these categories and we don't
miss out on things I think one of the
things that our team did is focus on
security security is one of the
forefront focuses of Schembri and on my
organization so identifying those
aspects those areas well it's very
important for us I won't cover every
aspect the ones that helped us
tremendously was providing consistencies
in our security policy and governance it
meant rethinking our approach
applications that sit on premises or in
public cloud application is an
application as an application the
security requirements are the same we
have to be paying much importance to
what our posture looks like regardless
whether it's in public or private cloud
it gave us an opportunity to look at our
existing landscape and improve our
security postures along with that there
was a tremendous amount of effort
invested by my security
architect by security organization to
invest effort into a secret management
approach working through our cloud
native solutions of offerings that are
available to manage our bring your to
apply or bring your own key strategy
extending our perimeter and also just
provide segmentation into our
environment that effort resulted in a
very key milestone that we achieved
where secret applications based on data
classification are not just welcomed
naturally preferred in public cloud that
is a tremendous achievement from my team
and the support from the whole
organization so that covers a security
aspect of it what I would like to go
next and the enterprise agility going
back to reducing friction so just sheer
mass scale of Schlumberger and the
amount of resources that were migrated
into the cloud it is incredibly
important to pay attention to how we
deployed our resources how did we
organize them how did we tag them label
them it has a significant impact on what
happens to our billing what happens to
our consistency in deployment and it
adds organized chaos let's just say
because we were we were learning as we
were doing things and it has helped us
to learn where we need to stop think
stop the bleeding and then keep moving
forward so what we have done is we have
implemented consistency and we have
tried our best and it's a work in
progress to introduce automation in that
consistency effort my architects and my
team is still continuously evolving
along with the cloud service providers
there were few services that were just
made GA last year that we ended up using
for that purpose and it has been
incredibly helpful next step cloud
transformation I think when we talk
about focus areas we cannot and ignore
cloud transmen transformation aspect I
as VMs is step one
at this point if we do not explore cloud
native services path services that are
available already it is an opportunity
lost so one of the things that my team
has invested effort with support from
application teams is do an assessment
for our application landscape from the
perspective of modernization what does
it take to improve the application
stance and actually deploy it in a pass
environment pass offerings that actually
add value to our business so those are
the ones that we focused on and we
worked with our cloud service providers
to meet the gaps to say let's go back to
engineering let's ask their help and
challenge and help them challenge us to
say where do we need to change our
standards and where do we need to go
ahead and maybe work with them to
introduce new features into the services
that has also tied back into our
security landscape because perimeter has
changed in the cloud it is no longer
just a firewall based perimeter so we
had to rethink our approach from API
management perspective and what has
environments and what controls do we
have to apply so it is an excepted
service offering that we can offer that
being said one of the things that we
have tremendously focused on is the
automation aspect yes you think about
how you deploy these services what
controls to apply everyone jumps to
compliance one of the things that we are
focusing on is consistency if we get to
a state of consistent resource
deployment it will be less of a battle
to get towards compliance and not that
we're not working towards it we're
working with our cloud service providers
to find better ways to meet that
compliance but we have to invest a
tremendous effort in a few things
infrastructure is code so doing
templating out what we are deploying and
with the support of our operations team
implementation of configuration
management system so every resource that
goes out there is out there in an
efficient optimized and consistent way
that has helped us tremendously and I
think it
we'll introduce tremendous amount of
optimization into our the way we work
and the buy-in from operations and the
organization has helped a lot there was
a lot of effort investing in
understanding what tools to use what
approach to go for it has been I think
one of the most revolutionary changes
and upscaling or our folks to learn
infrastructure as code and the technical
skill set that applies to it that leads
into our service operations piece
yes automation is good but you have no
idea what to automate until you actually
manually try out the process so one
thing that we did is we had a consistent
cloud hosting process so the work that
our operations team the delivery team
was doing is now exposed to the rest of
the organization to utilize the services
that the team has to offer
and it is a simplified approach so you
don't have a lot of fields a lot of
questions to answer to get resources in
cloud that is also a work in progress as
people start learning and it is a
massive organization to distribute that
information that this service is
actually available my team has done a
tremendous job in presenting these
offerings and services and the way that
we are implementing this process and
getting the feedback and iterating it
over and over again we apply our
learnings as soon as we can and we would
try to change as much as we can as fast
as we can and these little building
blocks has helped us put the pieces and
foundation together so for our service
offerings we can automate these pieces
so that is also a work in progress for
us that when we see our final vision
that a bazaar will talk next about for
our service management on automation
pieces that how these efforts are lining
up for a bigger vision for our
organization and lastly community of
practice it's very close to my heart and
this is what ties into change management
our learnings our training
our sessions our reference architectures
from our POCs for our past environments
and modernisations working with our
cloud service providers partners Tam's
learning from them getting that
information getting that training
scheduled and being proactive about it
and getting that knowledge to our teams
so it encourages cloud adoption when
they take their first step they're not
scared they don't know where do I go
next how do I get my Google project how
do I go ahead and start these services
do we have direction can I go through my
qualification processes as I go ahead
and embark on this journey
the idea is to spread that knowledge as
much as we can so these pieces with our
guiding principles of cloud first with
the direction to reduce friction with
the direction to say yes we will select
cloud native offerings we have a bias
towards it because we have chose that
way and we have partner with our cloud
service providers to help reduce
friction in these areas that is where
our efforts every work stream every task
every discussion that is how we make
decisions for each organization that
goes on this journey your implementation
is going to be different because your
landscape is different
ours has changed significantly our
learning the way we go around and it's a
massive organization we figure new
things out every day but I hope this
actually provides information and
insight and if it seems like a daunting
task because it is a daunting task that
being said I'd like to call Bazaar back
up on stage or service automation
management and automation piece Thank
You Satya thank you very much for that
so guys basically this this piece of
work is is is our way of sharing for
those of you who are going to embark on
this journey or those of you who are
already on this journey to to know that
some of the pain points that you feel
that you see are some of the pain points
that most large organizations will
invest time and
effort in learning and actually building
what I would like to to talk a bit about
in the next slide is service management
and automation
as a part of our journey one of the
things that happened is that we chose to
bring managed services in-house now for
those of you who have who have managed
services in-house you probably know that
this is this itself is is is a very
large beast to deal with now when we
talk about service management and and
automation we are talking about building
the blocks that will help ensure that we
can support the operations of our
applications once they are residing in
public cloud and we are trying to bring
those applications and we are trying to
also align this with our core petals of
our savings and optimizations ability to
provide our agility simplicity and the
enablement of technology solutions and
services so I will break this up into
two core areas for those of you who are
already on this journey you you you you
probably will be able to associate with
us one of the major areas is for us to
be able to build a service catalog
basically a understanding of what our IT
services are going to be what are our
core services that we need to manage
because of our applications primary
residing in the infrastructure as a
service and then subsequently moving
into paths and and other SAS offerings
of the public cloud it was important for
us to focus on what we have and what we
need to support in infrastructure as a
service today so as a result the need
for a Service Catalog became imperative
it was important for us to know what is
it that we are going to support but not
only what are we going to support for
our internal customers but also how are
we going to support and measure this
against the SLA s so the journey was to
build a catalog that will allow us to
understand that promote that and be able
to advocate our services to our to our
wider organization at the same time
build the knowledge and the know-how of
how those services are going to be
supported with the growing technology
and the changing technology with our
public cloud service providers one of
those things that I have learned over
the last two and
half years is that it's like a six-week
sprint if not lesser where by the time
you you you have a a problem there is an
a solution most likely an alpha so you
you have to be ready you have to be
prepared you have to be adopting and
adapting these to be able to provide
these as a service to your to your
larger organization with the service
management one of the core things that
we have now is a a a dynamic and a
growing service catalog that allows us
to be able to support applications
across the the the fleet in terms of
what services can we offer with our
backup and restoration and some of that
we will talk about in in our operations
discussion and then as we as we
journeyed along one of the bigger
objectives we had was to be able to
achieve savings and savings in the sense
tangible dollar value savings that we
can show to our leadership as a part of
moving from our legacy data centers into
public cloud one of those things that
you will see in in in in one of the
other slides that are to come is that it
is heavily perceived that when you move
to public cloud that you start saving
instantly now one of those things that
you will you for those of you who've
already been there will know that
savings is is is is something that you
can achieve you will achieve but it
requires a level of education it
requires a level of commitment in terms
of optimizing and more importantly
automating your services to be able to
achieve those those savings and actually
realize them because your usage in in
cloud in public cloud is so dynamic that
if you're not aware if you're not
cognizant of this very quickly you will
you will start burning holes into your
savings so with service management and
putting a catalog together it was
important for us to start looking at how
do we automate some of those services to
be able to truly convert what we were
saying into tangible dollar values so
your automation is is is quite widely
spoken and abused terminology when we
talk about automation what we are
talking about is some simple ways of how
we can convert today that we cannot do
in in our legacy data centers and is
readily available in our public cloud to
true dollar value savings so an example
that I would like to share with you is
our ability to measure our Billings over
three-month cycle and then optimize what
what our configurations need to be and
this is really basic and simple so today
if if you have an application that has a
month end or a quarter end or a year end
requirement in your legacy data centers
what you will see is that those
applications are actually billed
configured and inspect to meet those
once-off expect deliverables what you
can do in cloud is you can actually
program you can automate this in in a
very simple way to ramp it up at month
end and ramp it down again after month
end to be able to pay those those high
compute high storage costs only when you
are actually using them and not for the
for the entire period that the
application is running so this was one
of those one of those areas simple areas
where we've been able to to automate our
presence in public cloud and be able to
save on on the compute and the the
operations cost of those applications
this is a journey that is that is going
to continue there is there's a lot more
that we we can and we will continue in
in the automation space to be able to
achieve our financial savings of being
in the in the public cloud but more
importantly it is also about how do we
optimize the presence of those those
applications one of the other examples
that we have is that there are
applications that we run that have
different environments and most most
organizations will be familiar with this
that for a good set of your applications
you would have your dev test and your
and and your your production
environments what public cloud will
allow you to do is you can automate the
shutdowns of your your non production
environments and be able to optimize on
the cost savings there by not having to
do to pay for those when you're not
using them so these are some of the the
learnings that we've had some of the
stuff that we've we've sort of gone
through and we've journeyed along and
and we realized that this is where the
the the the true rubber hits the road
when it comes to your savings and
optimizations at the same time with
automation it gives us the ability to
provide agility if there is a a a
concept an idea that that has that
requires a an infrastructure to be able
to test to be able to evaluate the
ability to do that in public cloud has
been a lot
later then it has been in the legacy
data centers for anyone who's who sort
of had you know outside outsourced data
centers you probably know that getting a
VM can take anywhere between two to six
weeks whereas if you have the right
processes and right automation tools
with within your cloud management system
you would be able to do that in in in
days if if not in in hours so what this
basically the the focus for the service
management and automation pillar which
was a dedicated pillar was to be able to
build that catalog and at the same time
convert all of those services is as
micro services that can then be tackled
and then be automated the question
should be what what do we do when you
are in are in in a multi multi cloud
environment and you need to be able to
not only automate but you also need to
be able to monitor your different
services and offerings across a variety
of the clouds this was this was
something that we we've sort of learned
and in hindsight things could be you
know there there are things that can be
done differently but one of the things
that we have done is we've gone out and
we said we will build a tool that will
give us the ability to absorb api's from
our various cloud environments and bring
it into a central portal where we can
not only have a visualization for our
application owners subsequently our
leadership to be able to see how the
applications are performing what the
compute were the cost for the storage
the licensing and and the various
components of the of the application are
but at the same time be able to then say
look at what are our high frequency
complex services that we need to provide
to our applications and how can we start
targeting automation around that so
we've achieved a certain level of
automation that has allowed us to
achieve a certain level of dollar value
savings which which is aligned with the
journey that we want to proceed and this
in 2019 is going to be our focus areas
as we journey along the modernization
and we continue to to optimize on our or
or our automation one of the things like
I said in in hindsight that could have
been done differently is is look at what
sales offerings and and
they're dueling methods are available in
the market out there and as and and it
is growing every day that can allow you
that flexibility so that is that is one
thing that I I think is is is is going
to be a focus area for for organizations
that are either embarking on this
journey or are already there and are
looking to see how they can optimize
their managed services what I would like
to do is I would like to sort of bring
our operations manager sherry Wheatley
to come and share with us some of her
findings and learnings that that has
helped make slumber J's cloud operations
a better place today sorry thank you
hello thank you for joining our session
today I'm going to talk a little bit
about operations and what we're doing we
we started pretty much early 2018
through where we are today right so our
vision was to bring cloud ops in-house
moving away from our providers so that
we could make sure that we support and
stabilize the applications that were
migrating over to the multi cloud
providers and that basically aligns with
our corporate digital strategy so we
started that we also started evaluating
tools automation and orchestration cloud
tolling we knew we needed something to
help with the cloud operations team and
people right people were very important
we had to figure out you know are we had
seniors guys in our group they were very
very good we also wanted to bring in
cloud knowledge so we looked forces
specific skillsets and capabilities and
made sure - we could handle the capacity
that was coming our way when it comes to
our data centers we have legacy data
centers multi we have kolos and we were
working on assessing where we could
actually start consolidating and closing
down and moving a lot of these
applications again to the cloud so when
we moved into 2019 we actually started
implementing the tooling that we did the
POC on that orchestration automation
hopefully it's going to gain
efficiencies and the plan is to reduce
cost as well it's optimized
and on the capacity in the sizing of the
VMS we also line our catalog so we
ensure that we're gonna work through our
SLA s to meet our customer requirements
and the business and at that time too
we're also reorganizing cloud ops to
actually join the applications team so
that google has been spending quite a
lot of time with us so that we could
adopt the s re model and then and DevOps
so that's what we're working through
which are very excited to do that more
and more the high valued applications
were moving into the cloud so we are
also setting up the follow the Sun we've
got critical applications that need to
be supported around around-the-clock
tech debt obsolescence that's a big
project this year I think a lot of
people are going through that and so
we're working on that figuring out what
can we modernize what do we need to do
can we decommission and yesterday really
exciting news from Google that we can
consider using the anthos tooling so be
looking into that and then one other
area that we need to really work on this
is something that we've been struggling
and I think we finally have a solution
and that's our monitoring right we can't
do well in the cloud without a good
application that we can monitor and
alerts and then last we're gonna
continue it's a journey right another 12
18 months but we're going to continue
working on reducing our internal data
centers on prim next I want to talk a
little bit about where we feel we are
today with cloud readiness there's at
five core areas first to the patching
and the backup right those two solutions
had to be in place before we could roll
out anything into the cloud the good
news is we were able to leverage and
extend our patching and our backup
tooling from on-prem to the cloud so
that worked out well provisioning we're
almost there but again until we start
using that cloud automation tooling
we're still running some scripts and
deploying begin so we want to be able to
bring those quicker to the market and
then we're looking to at working through
on disaster recovery it's more of
slumber J I mean dr it's there right in
the cloud but we spent a great deal of
time you know security requirements
working with the team
I had to deal with the data residency we
had to deal with the sensitive and the
confidential data so that's kind of
slowed us down but we're there we're now
able to deploy those systems in the
cloud so our architecture team Satya
the lead she'll be working on bringing
us a solution later this year and last I
want to talk a little bit about security
I think everybody knows it's always a
challenge you know every time we turn
around there's new vulnerabilities you
know how do we capture these how do we
patch these quick enough so we've
partnered with our security teams and
they're working with us to bring us some
tooling simplify some of the process
deliver it reporting as well as
dashboards we need that visibility and
it's important not just for the team but
for the management in general so that's
that's where we're at and I'll turn it
back over to a bizarre so guys again
just very just recapping on this for
those organizations that have operations
in-house it is it is one of those areas
where I think I can say this as as as
candidly as possible it is the most
thankless area to be in it is an area
where you have to keep the lights on and
you you have to to continue to keep
doing more with less what sherry has has
shared with us is that along the journey
since 2000 and and 17 as we started to
move the first application and had to
start supporting it there was a barrage
of things that we had to take on board
and we had to to make sure that we were
not only equipped in terms of our
capabilities but also from our capacity
point of view to be able to support some
of those things that were that were
previously being done by an outside or
an outsource service provider what you
see in the the the quadrant where we are
talking about our cloud readiness one of
the things that I think we we want to be
we want to elaborate on is that this is
our unlike any other organization
sometimes you are the victim of your own
processes and we have been we have been
through that journey especially when it
comes around data residency when it
comes around security when it comes
around areas where you can actually
where you
dealing with with client data it it puts
some limitations around what you can and
cannot do what you see over there is
what is what that journey has been in
2017 onwards for slumber J to grow its
its cloud its readiness in those five
core areas in terms of being able to
adopt and adapt what the the offerings
have been from the native cloud at the
same time there are there are areas
where we had to go and build certain
solutions because of the the lack of
those solutions meeting our own
requirements especially in the in the
backup in the restoration space where we
had very specific application
requirements that had to be catered to
so it's been a journey and and this is
is is important to call out because the
the growth that you see today the
ability that we have and the presence
that we have today for an organization
as large as slumber J with as archaic
applications and and processes and
technology debt that we have to be able
to comfortably stand up and say yes we
have a very strong footing today in in a
multi cloud environment to the position
where we can actually stand and share
our learnings with you has required us
to work very closely with our partners
you know with with with our multi cloud
service partners our application
development partners to make sure that
this is a robust footing for our our
future state our modernization and the
journey that we want to carry on with
where we can start to pass our
applications and and then subsequently
containerize them this slide is a slide
that I think anyone who has who has ever
worked with
with a a large organization no matter
what project you are on can can
associate with so what I'm not going to
go through every every one of these but
one of the challenges that if you are
already on the journey or if you are are
starting this journey or if you're
thinking about starting this journey and
there are certain areas which are
daunting food for thought is that there
are certain competing priorities that
you would always have to deal with and
we were no different there were multiple
large programs that were running in
parallel that were sucking most of our
our resources as a result of which
capability of being able to do this in a
quicker in a more effective manner was
compromised
there is a perception that you know
cloud is cheap but like I said before it
comes at a cost it comes at a an
awareness and a learning and we need to
be be mindful of that security is again
one of those areas that every
organization will have some challenges
around knowledge and bandwidth again as
as you journey into cloud and the rate
at which our public and private cloud is
growing you will realize that this is a
constant learning and as as sadia
pointed out you know the the the areas
where we are focusing in is making sure
that as we grow the skills within our
with our teams we grow the skills
through proper training and and
partnering with with with our cloud
service providers license validation and
budget yes there's always a constraint
of budget I don't think there's anyone
in the room who will who will deny that
you know money is abundance and that you
could you could you could go out and do
what you want to so there's always a
need for us to be able to to play smart
in that space and it's going to be one
of the the challenges that we have to
deal with and I think this sort of
basically brings us to the slide where
we it's it's a lighter way of putting
together what our journey has has looked
like since we started the the journey it
was you know the the perception that the
leadership team mostly have is that
moving to cloud as snap of a finger
right you pick your applications you
move them but when you when you go
through the journey there's a lot of
learning so this slide basically helps
me summarize the you know the blurb that
we've just been going on for the last 42
minutes now in a nutshell it does
require a significant amount of
pre-planning so that your efforts during
your migration your failures during the
journey of actually moving the
applications are significantly reduced
so the area where I think everyone who's
who's embarking on this journey should
focus on is a detailed assessment it's
it's imperative that you know what
you're dealing with it's imperative that
you know what your your your what is the
workload that you're carrying with you
what is the debt that you're carrying
with you so that you can make a fair
assessment it's important to understand
that cloud first is is a strategy that
most organizations have gotten uh
promotes that as well but at the same
time
cloudy fright should not be overseen
what I mean by that is that you you as
an organization would know what is the
lifespan of your applications what is
the the future state of your
applications and that would that through
your assessment process will help you
qualify whether the application is ready
for public cloud and whether you want to
make the amount of investment that would
be required in some cases to actually
cut across the line on that side the
other thing that you all that that we
learned as a part of the journey is that
it is important to to go down a proof of
concept to be able to validate two
things one how simple complex or or
super complex your applications are and
secondly what is the right methodology
for your migrations is it a lift and
shift or is it a rebuild greenfield or
is it a combination what is it because
this will help you with two main things
one you will be able to plan and and
have a road map based on your capacity
constraints with your competing
priorities your budgeting constraints
your licensing constraint etc on what
that road map is going to look like but
at the same time it will help you
partner in with the right integration
partners so one of the things that we
learned as a journey is that we did not
have all the know-how of the tools of
the people and we needed to partner in
with the right people to help us make
that journey as you as you journey
through that you in 2017 once we had
completed a a thorough proof-of-concept
we done our assessment we done a a good
set of applications that gave us a level
of comfort 2017 was more on taking a
substantial amount of our landscape and
and and actually running that through to
be able to validate that our Cole vision
around savings and optimizations agility
simplicity and enablement of technology
was was actually going to be achieved so
this was just us revalidating that that
is that was that was all still
deliverable and 2018 was then you roll
so that is when we were we were very
focused we had we had our objectives
aligned across the organization and the
focus was on on on on killing our data
center and moving into cloud and to
18 and 2019 was about building our
roadmap for what the future is going to
look like how are we going to focus on
our modernization and how are we going
to take the journey into now exploiting
what the cloud has to offer so basically
in on a light note this is where where
we are I would like to share a picture
of the team that has been a you know the
backbone not everyone is over here but
this is the team that has helped
significantly work with us
on this slide I also want to take the
opportunity to stand here we wouldn't be
standing here and I wouldn't have had
the opportunity to be here if it was a
not because of the team that is that is
right behind me
literally at the moment to support this
journey but also I want to thank our
partners and I would like to name a few
of them who've been you know very
pivotal in the journey with us to start
off with Google who's who's partnered
with us throughout the journey and their
engineering has helped us support and
build for our present and our future
state we work very closely with our
cloud providers in Microsoft we've
worked with Capgemini KPMG at AWS
Hitachi to name a few and and without
this support without their support
without their partnering and as I said
at the start of it this was this is the
wealth that we we've built these are our
resources these are the people who've
actually brought the skills the team the
the tools and more importantly the the
attitude the can-do attitude to make
this a success so I want to thank the
people who've been a part of this
journey I know that you know we've we've
we've shared some a lot of the stuff
that you've probably heard before but if
there's anything that we can we can
share or leave with people who are
embarking on this journey we'll be more
than happy to do that
[Music]